that's all I love these safe stations we
can learn a save station same stations
these things gotta let us see the same
stations gotta let my stations same
stations gotta let my phaz Asian same
stations gotta let my suggestions
same station sleeping my see using safe
station gotta love a same stations ha ha
stations Asians gotta take a break
actually
Colette's new stations
[Music]
paddle their mouths they use the things
in the show
oh say use Asian without us getting
Nicole this station just gotta love
miles Legion Stadium
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] same station say
you gotta let my sleeves and saves
patients can live iciest agency use
asian asian asian singing the station's
got it I'm a CIA agent
I live my station paper station is a
station being station
samesies alien sorry I don't wake I've
seen that
save stations gotta let mercy seasons
sorry I burped excuse me I'll excuse me
princess
I thought I saw a power note